just landed la like first stop in and
out animal style crazy time something
wrapped in like I don't I don't know
what any of these things are it's kind
of like the West Coast staple fast-food
restaurant right I have not had the
secret menu and now someone told me
about it it didn't sound that appealing
uh the secret menu
I don't know how secret it is what um so
there's no bottom of the flying dutchman
I see nothing Dutch nor flying about
this I don't think it looks like a
burger at all looks like a smiley face
yeah it's like a grilled cheese made of
meat hmm it is just like an incomplete
experience opposed to have a bun and
stuff how am i order it with the salad
do this salad sir
oh it's lettuce I feel like the point of
a bun is to sort of like hold everything
together and I'm not sure this lettuce
is doing a good job
you'd think protein style would mean
more protein maybe like chicken breasts
as the bun it's like a giant salad that
you can hold and it's filled with meat
that sounds good
I di feel like anything tastes good if
you put enough like Thousand Island
dressing on it this is good I like this
I'll go for this okay I feel like this
is the one that I've heard about I don't
know what that what it means this one
has a bun which is comforting to me no I
don't I still don't know what is
misleading taste that different to me it
is pretty regular guys it's not like
meat style it's not covered in animal
like a salty cheesy good time
mmm okay I like it mm-hmm I like this
this has got to be a joke because this
is just a burger without a patty right
so it doesn't look bad it just doesn't
look like a grilled cheese I feel like
you could do a way better job making a
grilled cheese at your house it just
makes me feel sad there's like they
forgot the burger Oh
all right it's all so good whoo love
dessert
oh I hate cold things mm-hmm is it again
really just like it's not so secret it's
more of just like a thing of convenience
just put all three kinds in one cup
there you go secret menu I don't know
it's a charming little menu you liked it
so far this way
here's more stuff on top of it the
secret seems to be that they thought of
all this stuff and it's not good enough
to be on the real menu so it's just like
there's a secret menu
the secret is this book that Oprah found
and she like became obsessed with it and
told everybody it would change their
lives or it's it's just feeling probably
a lot more sauce